Für Geert Deneire sind es lange Tage
auf dem Feld.
In diesen Wochen ist Erntezeit.
Der flämische Landwirt bringt Lauch
und Kartoffeln ein, mehrere Tonnen pro Tag.
Wir sind im westlichen Zipfel Belgiens
in der flämischen Provinz Westflandern.
Das Besondere in dieser Region:
Landwirte ernten hier nicht nur Gemüse,
sondern graben auch andere,
höchst brisante Kaliber aus.
Geert Deneire zeigt uns seinen jüngsten
Fund mitten aus seinem Lauchfeld:
eine Granate aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg.
Mein Vater hätte sogar gewusst, ob das
eine englische oder deutsche ist.
Ich weiß das nicht.
Aber diese hier ist nicht gefährlich.
Vielleicht ist noch ein bisschen
Munition drin,
aber da ist der Sprengkopf schon ab.
Geert Deneire weiß:
Eine Garantie gibt es nie.
Solche Funde können jederzeit
hochgehen.
Immer wieder kommt es zu
tödlichen Unfällen.
Angst hat er keine –
so eine Kiste voller Sprengköpfe
gehört hier einfach zum Alltag.
Ich war noch ganz klein,
da hab ich das erste Mal so etwas gefunden.
Das war normal.
Das stammt alles noch vom Krieg.
Kaum eine andere Region ist vom
Ersten Weltkrieg noch heute so geprägt
wie die Provinz um Ypern.
Die Landschaft erzählt ihre
eigene Geschichte:
Soldatenfriedhöfe säumen die Wege.
Hier entlang zog sich die Frontlinie.
Heutige Felder waren einstmals Schauplatz
bitterster Schlachten.
Militärstützpunkt Poelkappelle:
Sergeant Major Gino Lambrecht
plant den Morgeneinsatz.
Seine Spezialeinheit rückt jeden Tag aus,
um Kriegsmunition zu bergen.
Es ist erst acht Uhr morgens, aber hier in
der Einsatzzentrale von Poelkappelle,
erzählt er uns, sind schon dreißig
Anrufe eingegangen.
Heute haben wir so viel Arbeit,
dass wir mit zwei Teams unterwegs sind –
hier auf der oberen Seite und hier unten.
Dort waren die Deutschen und hier die
Briten, die Franzosen oder auch Belgier.
Und die hatten alle unterschiedliche
Typen von Kriegsmunition.
Erster Einsatz an diesem Morgen:
eine Baustelle.
Arbeiter sind auf Munition gestoßen.
Jetzt muss Gino mit seinen Männern ran.
Wir begleiten sie,
müssen aber auf Abstand bleiben.
Erst beurteilt die belgische Spezialeinheit
die Lage, dann dürfen auch wir näher ran.
Der Fund: 12 deutsche Granaten
und eine britische.
Alle stammen aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg –
vermutlich Giftgas.
Hier habe ich eine, die noch einen
Sicherheitszünder hat.
Daher kann ich sagen, die ist noch scharf,
die ist noch nicht explodiert.
Manchmal ist die Zündschnur in so
schlechtem Zustand,
dass es tatsächlich noch gefährlich
werden kann.
Das muss ich alles bewerten,
auch ob der Fund toxisch ist oder nicht.
Du weißt im Voraus nie, was du kriegst.
Daher gilt immer,
erst den Fund zu beurteilen.
Dafür sind wir ausgebildet,
um abzuschätzen, wie groß die Gefahr ist,
wie wir vor Ort handeln müssen.
Das hier ist eine Gasmaske, die schützt uns
vor eventuellen toxischen Gasen,
die in Kriegsmunition vorkommen kann.
Geschätzte 1,5 Milliarden Projektile
wurden im Ersten Weltkrieg abgefeuert.
Die meisten davon sind rund um Ypern
tief im Erdreich begraben.
Experten gehen davon aus,
dass 30 Prozent davon noch heute als
Blindgänger hier liegen – scharfe Munition.
Austretende Gase vergiften die Böden,
immer wieder gibt es Verletzte –
entsprechend hoch die Alarmbereitschaft
für die Spezialeinheit von Poelkappelle.
Wir müssen binnen drei Tagen
das Material bergen, so ist es vereinbart
zwischen dem Verteidigungsministerium
und der belgischen Regierung.
Mit dem Fund geht es zur Zentrale:
200 Tonnen Kriegsmunition
kommen hier jedes Jahr an.
Auf eigens präpariertem Gelände
versenkt das Militär die Sprengsätze,
dann lassen Fachkräfte
sie kontrolliert detonieren.
Poelkapelle kann alle Typen von
Kriegsmunition auf der Anlage zerstören,
auch toxische.
In einem aufwendigen Verfahren bestimmen
Experten die Art der gefährlichen Gase,
um sie entsprechend zu neutralisieren.
Zurück im Einsatz: Sergeant Lambrecht
erreicht wieder ein Anruf,
diesmal unweit der französischen Grenze –
eine weitere Granate.
Einhundert Jahre
nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg
ist das tödliche Erbe der Vergangenheit
für die Menschen hier immer noch Realität.
Sie alle hier in Belgien leben mit einem
Stück bitterster Weltgeschichte,
Tag für Tag.
So wie Landwirt Geert Deneire mussten
sie lernen, damit umzugehen –
jeder auf seine Art.